i what i did want to say you know over
the weekend I was surprised right so I
tweeted out that uh rich Voss I was
sorry it's just sitting there looking at
my mentions you know and one of the
listeners to this show tweets out what
he's watching on his TV on a Saturday
morning I think was Saturday and it's a
it's a video from the Sirius XM app so
the Sirius XM app now has tunned like it
every day they're posting a new video
from the show and the Sirius XM AF has
its own app for Apple TV so it looks
amazing
on TV sets and whatnot right so they
were like this is what I'm watching on a
Saturday morning and it was Voss his
appearance from Thursday on the show and
I didn't even realize they were gonna
make a video out of this but Voss
started talking about it the creeps with
kids to her with food in his mouth which
he always does he always takes a bite
right before he's gonna say something
yeah so I yelled at him about it and Jim
yelled at him about it and he spit his
food out on like a tray in front of
everybody yet and I'm like yelling I'm
going what are you doing just let me
talk let me filled
let me fill the air you finish your
bites disgusting right it was revolting
so and I said all that so they put that
they left it on the video which by the
way I don't know if it was a serious XM
video team or our team I'm assuming it
was the video team fabulous instincts I
love that that was left on the video it
should have been left on the video it's
the first thing you see the intro comes
on and then Voss spitting his food out
if you want to see the the video you can
go on the Sirius XM app and you can see
it it's amazing so I simply tweeted out
I said oh my god
thanks to the Sirius XM app you can see
Voss spitting his breakfast out on your
TV set great plug write great plug right
so
on Instagram later in the day and you
know I flip back and forth between these
social medias yes you know all the
different social medias I flipped back
and forth and I see I've got an alert
that somebody has mentioned me in their
story homeboy and it's one Robert Kelly
hmm who is on the creeps with kids to
her and he's traveling with Voss so this
is what I saw in the stories I believe I
believe this is the first video mmm
maybe where's my list of oh yeah they're
listed 1 2 3 so let's see Bob cam fan
cam yeah that's the first one yeah okay
yeah yep okay let's go to uh let's go to
video number one this is this came to me
via Instagram stories you keep blogging
you can't block Sam Roberts I go in to
do the radios No thank you for having me
for a second
there people noticed that too he can't
put his glasses I was trying to make a
point you can rewind a little bit I
don't want to interrupt him thank you
for having me
then Sam right oh my god
thanks is yours attempt you can now
watch rich boss with his breath and
sound on television Sam just posted he
still got you on insta
so Yvonne he blocked me he blocked me
because
I tweeted about him spinning out his
breakfast he thought that was he said
that's a negative thing you don't do
that to me mmm and I was like bro you're
the one to spit your breakfast out
mm-hmm I just tweeted out that you can
see you spitting your breakfast out on
it there is this thing like for instance
if I was like you could see Ian's
finances mustache on the Sirius XM app
would you take that as a negative or
positive I take it as a positive and I
go one more and say hey do I have it I
take care of it - that's right right now
if you go in - seriously why not right
now but later on in the day if you look
at the Sirius XM app you can see Ian's
finance combing his mustache uh-huh
now if Ian's finance did not want his
mustache to be combed on camera he
shouldn't have done it in the should
have done it shave that stache raft
before you come in here otherwise it's
for the world over my dead body if you
don't want people to watch you spitting
your breakfast out like a child on their
television sets finish your bites yeah
more maybe just take bites that you can
handle mm-hmm so or be a be a good
partner and swallow okay that's weird
the way you looked at me when you did
that cuz your eyebrows went up again
it's a great material for the app weird
visual so then I tweet out you know kind
of being good hearted about it yes still
got you on insta at rich voice and I put
that on my Instagram stories Bob Kelly
being the good person that he is let
rich know yes see I wrote still got you
on insta at Rich DeVos Bob Kelly an
exclamation point just fun we're foot
we're still having hard ribbing we're
striving fun right a little bit of Isis
I thought intelligence am just posted he
still got you on insta boss oh let me
explain something to you when you get
blocked on Twitter yeah and if I have
time then I go to Instagram yeah he just
got me you lose I didn't block by the
way he's acting like I got you like as
in gotcha yeah yeah sick no I'm saying I
got you as a friend on Instagram like
hey Troy guess what I got you on Twitter
and Instagram I got you well the way
Bobby said it put an inflection on it
like ooh
why not you I've to tell you something
huh I deeply appreciate Robert Kelly's
role in this entire city yes I think he
is Jeff red oval firestarter it's like a
prodigy song and you're sitting there
and they're driving down to town
mm-hmm the entertainment that he's
making for himself by creating this
whole thing amazing I deeply and
profoundly respect and also I love the
camera angle because vlog mr. Magoo
Bobby picks the least flattering camera
for rich and then goes like hey how much
of an [ __ ] is Sam huh get right up
his nose it's funny too when people have
glasses that the lenses make their eyes
look big right and you get real close so
it's like oh my god you're Madhu Steen
of straw so rich blocked me on Instagram
yes and then he blocked me from Jim
Florentines account which I was like
okay there's a real fire here yeah
there's some real stuff for me to deal
with this is tough mm-hmm
this is really really tough how did you
react uh I apologize to jim Florentine
because rich said rich said he wouldn't
unblock me until I had him in studio and
he I apologized to him for being
negative which I don't see what on earth
I would apologize to rich for now while
this is going on people can still he's
blocked you but the food spitting out is
still floating around that's on the
Sirius XM M for everyone to see mm-hmm
and also since somebody took a video of
them watching their TV it's on that is
that song yeah I tweeted it yeah I
tweeted it for everybody to see yes and
then then we got word from Florentine
and Voss this was what no no yeah yeah
this was after the creeps with kids show
and they give a taste of what happened
at the creeps with kids show in this
story Bob actually did some video
editing for his Instagram
you see this
got he killed awesome yeah Boston sold
out phenomenal
Ronnie murdered you murdered everybody
boss murdered [ __ ] I killed it
my favorite part was the panel bosses
tell my mother I was gay yeah and then
we reaffirmed their like six other times
to your family that was sitting in the
bow yeah that was the without a doubt he
said my favorite part was this and then
it went to like a star white yeah that's
a great transition it was a great
transition and then it went to the stage
this was actually happening at a
sold-out Wilbur theater at the creeps
with kids to her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow whoa yeah and then they wrote a
hashtag black Sam Roberts I mean this is
war I mean you know why I first was like
oh maybe this is war and then you don't
really started getting way more like
than anybody blocking me was everybody
sending me screenshots every person who
listens to the show sending me
screenshots of one rich block of them
too so yeah so so ultimately rich Voss
did get a theater of comedy fans to
block me because I tweeted out that you
could see him spinning his breakfast out
on television Wow all the more reason
for you to be mayor of Westchester
County obviously I make an impact at
that point and block Voss from ever
entering West Chester you won't be
allowed yeah yeah the boss memorandum I
would love to have us back in you will
be shocked
there will be no apology ever there will
never be an apology but it was great
watching it all go down that's great and
you're just sitting at home enjoying it
yeah I even have to leave the house I
didn't go to Boston and talk to anybody
I just sat there and I was like this is
great Mary in Philly what's up Mary hey
Sam hey Mary how you doing I really like
you I think you're great at what you do
in your profession you're excellent
but since Richard ever since he comes on
the show every single time you are out
you down him and you always put him down
you'll meet your kind of means and we're
because I think your real quick and
you're witty and you're smart and you
just you kind of like hammer him down
constantly look rich Voss rich Ross is
one of the top professional comedians in
all of the land yes like please do not
sit here and tell me that I am punching
down when Rich Voss is here rich Ross is
fully capable legend of defending
himself I am no stand-up comedian Reggie
was a legendary stand-up comedian who
has traded barbs with some of the best
yes can take a hit better than anyone
else and dish it back better than
anybody gives it to you what a treat
right what a treat indeed yeah but if
anybody if he in finance was in here
taking bites of food right like it go if
I asked even if I danced a question
right and then he took a bite right
before he answered I'd be like Ian are
you some kind of idiot
why would you take a bite of food before
you answer the question has nothing to
do with a prejudice against Voss and if
anything I'm far more comfortable yes
hate to act not the person right I'm far
more comfortable going after Voss
because I know of anybody not only can
he take it but he's gonna hit me back
way harder yep I would hate to see the
fight between you and loss or the
negativity or the bad feelings hurt him
in his relationship you mean because Jim
would be forced to take a side mmm in
the great battle comfortable you know
I'll tell you this Mary I'll tell you
this about rich Voss for a long time he
and I were both in a rivalry with an
actor named Kevin Pollak quite that's
right we were together we were brothers
in arm in a battle against actor Kevin
Pollak and what rich Voss would say is
his quote and I always loved it
rich Voss would say I don't give a [ __ ]
about him I'm living rent-free in his
head and I have to tell you I have to
tell you that quote struck me yes
because as I was sitting at home in the
comfort of my own palatial Westchester
estate on my couch watching my TV
you know not not having to do anything I
was witnessing that while vos was part
of one of the biggest comedy tours of
the year it felt to me like maybe just
maybe the last professional broadcaster
Sam Roberts was living rent-free inside
the the cranium of rich Voss one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the SiriusXM app
[Music]